and i mean it makes me wonder what
looking at some of the
biggest leaders in human history to ask
the question of
what was the motivation what was the
motivation for even just the
revolutionaries like lennon trotsky
and stalin what was the motivation
because it sure as hell
seems like the motivation was at least
in part
the driven by the idea
by ideas not self interest of like power
for lennon it was i think he was a true
believer and an actual narcissist who
thought he was the only one who could do
it
stalin i do think just wanted power and
realize well i don't know look he wrote
very passionately when he was young
and he was he really believed in
communism in the beginning he did
i i i always what i'm always fascinated
is i'm like
around 1920 what happened right
post-revolution
you crushed the whites now it's all
about consolidation
that's where the games really begin yeah
and i'm like i don't think that was
about communism
yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah maybe it became a useful propaganda
tool but it still
seemed like he believed in it uh whether
it was of course
this the question i mean this is the
problem with uh conspiracy theories for
me
and this is legitimate criticism towards
me about conspiracy theories which is
uh you know just because you're not like
this doesn't mean
others aren't like this so like i can't
believe that somebody'd be
like deeply two-faced oh i've met them
you're welcome to washington but like
i think that i would be able to detect
like no people are good well this
my question is well so this difference
this
this two-face like uh there's different
levels of two-face like what i mean is
to be killing people
and uh it's like house of cards style
right and and still present the front
like you're
you're like you're not killing people i
don't know
if i guess it's possible but i just
don't see that
at scale uh like there's a lot of people
like that and i don't
i have trouble imagining um
some you know that's such a compelling
narrative that people
like to say like people
that's the conspiratorial mindset i
think that skepticism was really
powerful and important to have because
it's true a lot of powerful people abuse
their power but saying that about
i feel like people over assume that
it's like i see that with the use of
steroids often in sports
people seem to make that claim about
like
everybody who's successful and i want to
be very
i don't know something about me wants to
be cautious because
uh i want to give people a chance being
purely cynical isn't helpful people say
that's about me he's always saying this
to do this
yeah but at the same time being naively
optimistic about everything is also
kind of productive because people are
going to [ __ ] you over
and more importantly that doesn't bother
me more importantly you're not going to
be able to reason about
how to create systems they're going to
be robust to corruption to uh
malevolent uh like parties so so
in order to create you have to have a
healthy balance of both i suppose
especially if you want to actually
engineer things that that that work in
this world that has evil in it
right i can't believe there's a book of
hitler on the desk
you